-Guys, do you ever see
a photo in the news
and think the headline
could be much better?
♪ -Yeah ♪
-Usher?
[ Laughter ]
-Take a seat, Usher.
-Usher -- he always wants
to get the last word.
-Always.
-Usher, are you okay with us
doing this bit?
♪ -Yeah ♪
[ Laughter ]
-Lil Jon?
♪ -Okay ♪
-Alright.
[ Laughter ]
It is time for
"News and Improved."
Here we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ -News and improved ♪
-For example, check out
this first photo.
The original headline was
"Matsuyama wins the Masters."
That headline can
definitely be improved
because if you only looked at
the photo, the headline
could have been "friend cancels
Zoom happy hour."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, too bad.
Let's check out
this next photo here.
The original headline was
"Biden unveils budget proposal."
-Oh, gosh.
-But if you only looked at
the photo, the headline
could have been "friends insist
Botox is 'barely noticeable.'"
[ Laughter and applause ]
-I can't tell. I can't tell.
-Up next, this headline says,
"Additional stimulus checks
debated."
Headline could have been,
"world's most annoying couple
signs dinner checks together."
[ Laughter and applause ]
"You write the tip."
"No, you write the tip."
"No, you write the tip.
Let's both write the tip."
[ Laughter ]
This next headline was
"Putin orders talks on
new tax incentives."
Headline could have been
"guys ask drunk friend
across the table if he's okay."
[ Laughter and applause ]
-"Right on. I'm great."
-Next headline was
"Merkel drafts new law."
Headline could have been
"woman hears about Usher paying
strippers with fake bills."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Up next, this headline says,
"Sanders backs union."
The headline could have been
"man enters 14th minute
of trying to get
bartender's attention."
[ Laughter and applause ]
"I'll just try -- try --
Just one -- Just --"
[ Laughter ]
Sex on the beach!
Next headline was
"administration kicks off
COVID relief tour."
Headline could have been
"man goes viral with blindfolded
stair descent challenge."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Next headline was "soccer teams
prepare for finals."
Headline could have been "man
charges phone for two hours,
realizes it wasn't plugged in."
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's all the time we have
for "News and Improved."